danielle simonnet bonjour bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation ce
matin sur rtl france alors pour
commencer la situation sanitaire avec le
variant delta le spectre d'une quatrième
vague à la rentrée jean castex a lancé
une concertation avec les élus locaux et
les présidents des groupes politiques
sur la question de la vaccination
obligatoire pour les soignants alors
vous vous êtes plutôt pour cette idée
d'obliger la vaccination notamment
soignants et côté il faut d'abord
encourager continuer à faire en sorte
qu'il ya une adhésion dans le pays au
vaccin il faut bien se rendre compte que
pour qu'on puisse avoir cette adhésion
au vaccin il faudrait que le
gouvernement fasse preuve vraiment bien
plus de pédagogie
mais vous savez tous les mensonges du
gouvernement pendant toute cette cette
année qui s'est écoulé de prix sanitaire
où on a eu droit au mensonge sur les
masques aux pipots sur les tests ont
aggravé la défiance finalement de la
population vis-à-vis de la parole
institutionnelle de ktm qui a été
décrédibilisée
or il ya un enjeu de santé publique que
tout le monde puisse se faire vacciner
pour absolument réduire les risques
d'une reprise de la pandémie
mais ce gouvernement au lieu d'essayer
de convaincre pense tout toujours
systématiquement et bien à l'obligation
à la répression aux côtés d'haïti sic et
il faut se rendre compte que aujourd'hui
si jamais on a une deuxième vague
nouvelle bague pardon avec le variant
delta il n'y a toujours pas l'ombre
d'une stratégie de planification
sanitaire de la part du gouvernement
l'état de l'hôpital public n'est
absolument pas améliorée depuis
depuis un an les choses qu'on continue à
se dégrader
donc il ya vraiment un problème global
dans la politique de ce gouvernement qui
ne mise pas vraiment sur la santé
publique qui a méprisé le personnel
hospitalier qui aujourd'hui ne voit pas
ses conditions de travail
grandement améliorée il est toujours en
situation de souffrance au travail
donc si on veut que les personnels de
santé et bien sûr vaccine parce que
c'est une urgence ni nécessité absolue
pour la santé publique de toutes et tous
et coupons l'est également sur leurs
conditions de travail
et arrêtons tous les projets aussi de
casse de l'hôpital public un jeu dira en
région parisienne par exemple vous avez
toujours un projet qui court de fusion
de deux hôpitaux bichat et beaujon pour
créer l'hôpital le grand hôpital nord
est qui va provoquer plus de 1000
suppressions d'emplois et 300
suppressions de liz est une aberration
totale au vu d' urgence de santé
publique alors une urgence de santé
publique autre préoccupation aussi pour
l'humanité c'est le climat et ce cri d'
alerte de l'ancien ministre nicolas
hulot il déplore le manque de réaction
de la classe politique après le rapport
du giec il y a quelques jours regarder
de droite ou de gauche
chacun devrait en prendre acte et dire
que maintenant c'est la priorité
ce qu'on pouvait faire en 30 ans on va
devoir le faire en quelques années
à un moment on ne va plus pouvoir
regarder nos enfants dans les yeux
la raison nicolas hulot les politiques
ne font pas assez pour le climat mais
bien sûr il faut complètement changer la
logique du système on est toujours dans
une logique productiviste et qui est
catastrophique la crise climatique elle
est irréversible et quand on voit par
exemple qu'en ce moment on a des 49 5
degrés au canada qu'on a comptabilisé
plus de 134 morts en cinq jours et que
ce qui préoccupe ce gouvernement où le
pouvoir médiatique dans sa majorité
c'est la question du burkina enfin vous
voyez l'état de d'irresponsabilité moi
je pense par exemple une question que ce
soit au vu de l'urgence sanitaire où que
ce soit au vu de l'urgence écologique
est il pertinent de maintenir
l'organisation par exemple des jeux
olympiques de tokyo qui vont enfin là
qui vont débuter
on voit bien que c'est une aberration
qui a un risque de reprise de la
pandémie était terrible est que ces
grands chamboulements ces grands
déplacements de 2,2 du monde entier pour
un événement sportif qui est le
l'événement le plus important
mondialement un impact écologique
extrêmement problématique
d'abord par tous les moyens de transport
qui vont être mobilisés pour déplacer
tant de populations et aussi par
chaque fois on est sur des grandes
infrastructures gigantesques qui ne
répond pas aux besoins et qui ont une
empreinte écologique extrêmement forte
il faut totalement changé notre mode de
développement notre mode de production
mais aussi notre mode de consommation
il faut bien prendre conscience que le
problème c'est pas ce qui va devenir va
advenir de la planète
le problème c est ce que notre
écosystème va permettre toujours que
nous puissions vivre
voilà la question vraiment de la survie
de notre humanité est en jeu et les
gouvernements continuent et fonce tête
baissée dans les mêmes logiques
productivistes qui a détruit notre
écosystème du coup je lisais vous êtes
conseillère de paris vous saluer la
politique de la maire de paris anne
hidalgo en matière justement de lutte
contre le réchauffement climatique
notamment avec plus de déplacements en
vélo
moins de voitures vous vous saluer c'est
cette position
alors écoute et qu'on essaye de réduire
la place et l'envahissement de la
voiture dans paris oui c'est une bonne
chose le problème c'est qu'on prend pas
le problème à la racine
pourquoi est ce qu'il y a autant de
déplacements subi il faut savoir qu'à
paris dans la petite couronne et dans
l'île de france
les déplacements entre le domicile et le
travail n'ont pas cessé d'augmenter ces
dernières années pourquoi parce que
beaucoup de personnes qui travaillent
dans paris n'ont pas les moyens de
pouvoir y vivre
c'est à dire que la logique spéculative
de la capitale
l'insuffisance de politique en parlant
par exemple du logement social ou de
l'encadrement des loyers est bien vague
d'il ya tout un tas d'hommes et de
femmes qui travaillent dans paris invité
toujours plus loin de paris et en même
temps on continue tête baissée à faire
une politique d'attractivité du
territoire c'est-à-dire avait on sortait
dans paris il ya plus d'emplois ils vont
créer plus d'emplois il n'ya de
population active donc on continue à
attirer des gens qui vont avoir des
déplacements subie contre un sur
l'intérieur de la capitale alors qu'il
faudrait relocaliser l'emploi dans les
villes et départements limitrophes où il
est déficitaire et donc c'est un peu
logique d'aménagement du territoire
aberrante et entier écologie la
métropolisation et entier l'écologie
après deuxième problème c'est que on
continue toujours des logiques du tout
béton dans la construction et au moment
de créer
veut pas les espaces de plein air il
faudrait au contraire augmenter les
espaces de pleine terre ferme vraiment
une stratégie de reconquête de la pleine
terre avec beaucoup plus d espaces verts
dans les centres villes notamment à
paris qui la vivent vraiment la plus
dense du monde avec à peine 100 mètres
carrés d'espacés verts par habitant
parce que sinon se provoquent les
problématiques d'îlots de chaleur et on
va aller on les a vus déjà dans les
précédents de canicule et on va les
avoir de plus en plus je vous propose de
rester à paris dans le nord de la
capitale plus précisément le quartier de
stalingrad 1 face à la présence de
toxicomanes qui empoisonnent la vie des
riverains
dans la nuit de mardi à mercredi ils ont
été évacués du jardin d'eole où ils se
regroupaient aucun lieu annoncé un pur
pour accueillir ces personnes désormais
regarder les mots d'anne hidalgo
justement pour régler durablement ce
problème là il faut une prise en charge
thérapeutique des personnes toxicomanes
il faut des médecins des addictologues
des psychiatres des infirmiers et
infirmières
il faut de l'hébergement qui n'existe
pas en nombre suffisant aujourd'hui pour
les personnes toxicomanes
si la demande que j'ai fait à l'état
alors comment on fait selon vous en quoi
on met des salles de shoot comme dans le
10e arrondissement par exemple plus de
structures d'accueil qu'est ce que vous
préconisez
alors ça s'appelle des salles de
consommation à moindre risque
c'est important de prendre le bon terme
et pas d'utiliser le terme
finalement qui est utilisé par l'extrême
droite la droite réactionnaire
ces salles de consommation à moindre
risque elles ont montré lors leur
capacité à contribuer à améliorer la
situation à paris et là si on est une
seule à gare du nord
mais rien que sept salles de
consommation à moindre risque à de l'art
du nord a permis de voir que hot ou via
des par exemple trois fois moins de
seringue dans l'espace public
là on voit un gouvernement inuits de
paris qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait vous
aviez une concentration de consommateurs
de crack de chasse qu'on appelle la
colline du crac ou donc la chapelle la
part de la chapelle où la ville a aussi
à staline râle on a déplacé le problème
pour les installer dans un jardin au
mépris de l'usaj premier de ce jardin et
de la population aux alentours on vient
à nouveau de les évacuer
mais sans aucune solution donc forcément
il continue de m
et à quelques mètres de là c'est
vraiment d'abord tout l'échec prévisible
de l'impact sécuritaire
il faut évidemment un salles de
consommation à moindre risque
2-2 l'hébergement avec l'accompagnement
social trois des maraudes avec un suivi
psychiatrique et il faut bien sûr en
terme de présence policière
une véritable stratégie de démantèlement
des trafics de crack
or sur ces surveillances l'ensemble de
ces propositions le gouvernement dans a
suivi aucune aucune
il est toujours là dans son débat
interne pour en compte les salles de
consommation à moindre risque et la
population dont peu plus parce que c'est
elle qui subissent une population des
quartiers populaires ils sont très
mobilisés et je les salue
ils voient bien de cette logique
sécuritaire ne fait que déplacer le
problème et qu'il va falloir enfin et
bien qu'il y ait ces mesures concrètes
qu'ils soient mis en place parce que si
on ne propose aucune solution pour que
les gens s'en sortent et bien le
problème reste entier
il faut bien prendre conscience aussi
que ont parlé tout à l'heure de la crise
de l'hôpital public
la crise de la psychiatrie est pire
encore
pire encore c'est vraiment un un secteur
qui a subi énormément de suppressions de
postes d'affaiblissement de ses moyens
alors que dans la lutte contre justement
les conduites addictives
l'accompagnement pour pour aider les
personnes à s'en sortir
eh bien on a besoin deux psychiatres on
a besoin de soignants et on a besoin
aussi de toutes nos politiques sociales
pour sortir de la rue ces consommateurs
de crack
alors on parlait d' anne hidalgo à
l'instant plus de 200 élus ont appelé la
mère de paris à se présenter pour les
présidentielles yannick jadot lui aussi
a officialisé sa candidature à la
primaire écologiste jean luc mélenchon
également un candidat à la
présidentielle et selon un sondage
harris interactive et bien 90 % des
électeurs de gauche estime qu'une
candidature unique serait une bonne
chose
vous seriez pour écouter vous savez j'en
ai je pas présenter sa candidature dès
le mois de novembre alors tout le monde
le disait oh là là c'est trop tôt
d'ailleurs que booster jandali se pose
la question à monsieur jadot à madame
hidalgo est ce que c'est pas trop tard
parce que en fait tous ceux qui
défendent est soi-disant l'unité des
primaires ou je ne sais quoi d'autre et
bien se retrouve à être candidats sans
programme sans équipe
regardez on sait que chez les verts
gérante écologie les verts il aura au
moins trois candidats que le ps on veut
absolument un qui sont pas en capacité
de se mettre d'accord entre eux élevés
et et le ps quel est l'enjeu de la
période et incarne la candidature de
jean élan champs dès le mois de novembre
il incarne la seule candidature en fait
pour un programme de rupture
le programme l'avenir en commun est un
programme de rupture j'en étais un jour
je pense est la seule personne qui est
en capacité de dire on va changer les
règles jeu de ce système qui provoque
l'exploit l'explosion de la misère et
des inégalités et la mise en danger
notre système parce qu'ils provoquent
propose la convocation de la
constituante
à l'issue de fond d'élection vous
constituante permettrait d' et bien à
l'ensemble du peuple de pouvoir
redéfinir les règles du jeu de notre de
nos institutions et donc de passer une
sixième république dans la période
c'est de cela dont on a besoin donc nous
vous proposons une stratégie bien
d'union populaire parce que là
maintenant il faut fédérer les citoyens
et citoyennes fédérer le peuple
souverain dans cette élection majeure de
2022 il peut enfin et bien ouvrir une
nouvelle nouvelle page de notre histoire
et là l'urgence ali à total merci
beaucoup à vous une énième simonet
d'avoir accepté notre invitation ce
matin dans la matinale de rtl france je
le rappelle vous êtes conseillère de
paris aura crise nationale de la france
insoumise
merci